and you're watching book TV on c-span -
and book TV is in London interviewing
some authors and joining us now is
Professor AC grayling the author of more
than 30 books his most recent is called
the God argument professor grayling in
that book you write the burdens of
religion are both social and political
what do you mean by that well we need
only look really across the landscape of
history to see how divisive how many
conflicts how many difficulties created
by divisions among people of religious
outlook the the burden there is is not
just an historical one it's also
contemporary when we look across
for example the Middle East and South
Asia we see these difficulties - and
they happen in our own societies and so
that there is a great burden now one
thing that I wanted to argue for in that
book was a different way of thinking
about the ethical which is to say all
those questions we asked ourselves about
how it should relate to one another what
our responsibilities are I wish you
choose lives that are good and
flourishing so that they don't cause
these divisions well professor hasn't
religion helped to define what good and
moral is people say this I'm the young
religions of the world Judaism
Christianity and Islam and I say young
because of course we look back across
two and a half three thousand years
perhaps but and that they are young
they've they've changed the way that
people relate to the world and to one
another quite dramatically if you look
at the ethical systems that they embody
all the very best of them they
adorations to care for the widows and
the orphans to treat our fellow human
beings as if they were our brothers and
sisters are common to all the great
ethical outlooks including the secular
the non-religious ones and insofar as
they have anything particular or special
to them and they do tend to generate
disagreements with the other ethical
outlooks and so that's I think where
some of the problem arises back to the
Gaad argument like magic and astrology
you right religion dates from mankind's
less educated and knowledgeable early
history and has been superseded by
advances in our understanding of the
world
our selves I think that's really obvious
in a way from when one looks it what
animism is and this is a term that
applies to the sort of pre revealed
religions of the world and which were
probably the dominant alcohol for many
many tens of thousands of years before
our own historical period and what you
see there is an attempt by human beings
to give some explanation to provide some
conceptual framework really for thinking
about the world the one thing that they
understood was agency they understood
their own capacity to pick up a stone
and throw it or to pour water or to make
a noise and so they thought that
everything that happened in nature must
have an agency behind it that the wind
the Thunder the the rain must be caused
by something rather similar to
themselves and that is a kind of proto
science that it's an attempt to provide
this explanatory framework of ideas and
if you look at how ideas about religion
have changed over the millennia you
notice that whereas the dryads and the
Nimbus and the sea gods and the and the
rain gods were present in nature but
they moved away as we understood more
about nature they went to the
mountaintops for example Olympus and
elsewhere in the Old Testament we have a
burning bush on the mountaintop and a
pillar of smoke by day it sounds like a
volcano God and then the gods went off
into the sky rah
and the Egyptians saw their God every
day burning in the sky the Sun but now
of course the the gods are beyond space
and time altogether and this I think
marks something of the horizon of the
advance of knowledge haven't we been
through these cycles before in our
history though where we think science
will supersede religion and and other
things well I did think science is ever
going to supersede our our ethical our
literary humanistic interests and it
doesn't claim to do so if you talk to
somebody working in one of the advanced
areas of science particle physics or
biology
they're concerned with a particular
range of natural phenomena and the
attempt to understand them the things
that we really value in our lives our
affections and our connectedness with
one another all the social and political
questions which are very great
importance in all
organizing and running society these are
not matters that an empirical scientist
can do more than contribute to and give
us help with understanding and with
facts but we all of us have to be
reflective and we all have to be part of
the great conversation of mankind where
we come to some decisions and
compromises about how we live together
professor grayling in the god argument
you argue for humanism what is humanism
humanism is an attitude rather than a
doctrine it's an attitude that says if
we're to think most fruitfully about our
human relationships our social and
individual relationships we've got to
start from our best our most generous
and sympathetic understanding of human
nature and the human condition now the
human condition of course is something
which is richly explored by literature
and history and philosophy understanding
human nature is much more difficult and
because it is so various and complex and
indeed it's a lifetime's work to try to
understand oneself let alone other
people given all the diversity of others
from one cells but that but that is
where we we have to start in order to be
able to work with the grain of human
nature and to try to be tolerant to give
other people the margin of possibility
for themselves to find lives that feel
good to them then one very key thing
here is this and for most of history
most people and alas still today have
been told that there is one right way to
live one great truth one answer to the
question of what it all means what the
Enlightenment of the 18th century
reminded us actually from classical
antiquity is that there is a great
diversity in human talent for good lives
there's a great diversity among human
beings I'm often put in mind of what
George Bernard Shaw said when he was
meditating on the golden rule you know
it says do to others as you would have
them do to you and he said under no
circumstances should you do to others
what you'd like them to do to you
because they may not like it this is a
very deep point it's a deep point
because it asks us to treat others in
their individuality and particularity
and to do that one has to have some
insight into human nature the best we
can get into this very complex matter
and that's why the demand is on us to to
be thoughtful to be observant to be
educated I mean in the
in the sensor we've become truly
reflective about the great range of
human possibilities and that is the
basis of a humanistic view in ethics
because it starts from the human at the
human scale looking for the things in
human life that tend to flourishing are
humans innately moral
intrinsically social animals essentially
social animals we need one an hour we
need to give and receive affection if
you look at our newspapers they're full
of atrocity and tragedy and conflict and
war but that's because those things in
news I mean in every town city village
of the world every single day of the
year there are millions of acts of
courtesy kindness common friendship
people just getting on the fact that the
buses run and the electricity comes on
mainly in most advanced economies is
because people are doing what they said
they would do that's the majority story
so we are I think fundamentally well
disposed towards one another and if you
wanted in astray ssin of why one would
think that suppose you were walking down
the street and you saw somebody ahead of
you on to whom a great pile of bricks
was about to fall unbeknownst to her
what would you do
you wouldn't say this is gonna be
interesting you'd say look out you cry
out to them and it wouldn't matter who
they are what their ethnicity what their
religion what their political views just
another human being and your instinct
would be to help them back to your book
the god argument
freedom from coercive ideology is both a
human right and a fundamental civil
liberty there's no question of it and I
think about the the major religions of
the world and the major political
ideologies of the Stalinist and Nazi
kind they share one thing in common that
is they have a view that they know how
things ought to be organized and
everybody's got to sign up for it this
is the one thing they have in common
this idea the structure of ideology
which forces onto people a particular
view in a particular practice and I
think every anybody would agree that
your right to freedom freedom of
expression to self-determination to
privacy these are things that you would
want to defend very robustly against
that is a totalitarian regime like the
Stalinist but insofar as the
honest regime shares with a major
religious outlook like the Catholic
Church of taqwa murder during the
Inquisition or like the the the
Calvinists of Geneva at the time of
Calvin himself you would see that
exactly the same thing applies freedom
from that kind of coercion over foreign
practice is a fundamental human right
and so one thing I argue in the book is
that we should refocus our thinking a
bit about this course people can choose
to believe what they like it of course
religious movements and and churches
have every right to exist and put their
point of view but no right to coerce
people into sharing that point of view
and alas most of history and too much of
the world today is still under the
government of coercion in that respect
this is book TV on c-span 2 and we are
in London and we're talking with various
authors while we're here today joining
us is Professor professor Anthony
grayling the god argument is his most
recent book professor while we're taping
this interview a new pope is being
chosen what are your thoughts about that
welcome me personally it's an
irrelevance it's a little bit of theater
it has a comic aspect to it but it also
has a serious aspect which is the course
that there are many hundreds of millions
of people who regard themselves as being
Roman Catholics who therefore be
influenced by the sorts of policies that
the new pope comes up with a
pre-scheduled be able to marry will
there be a change of view about
contraception will the the moral
teaching of the church become more
liberal or more will remain rather
authoritarian and these are matters that
impact on people's lives principally by
the way since the great majority of
members of the Roman Catholic Church use
contraception let us say there are an
odds with the official teaching of their
church and unfortunately obliged in the
interests of their own children and the
interests of their own lives to embrace
hypocrisy which is what ultimately it
comes down to that's a hard word but
alas it's true and I think people would
like to live with consistency and be
able to feel that they live with some
degree of integrity in
but the the way that these very ancient
doctrines apply to modernize does cause
a great deal of distortion and that's
one example with regard to humanism you
talk about different legislate
legislation that can happen such as drug
legalization why is that a humanistic
approach well the in in direct route to
a view about what kind of public policy
might be based on humanistic ethics must
always take into account the fact that
what we're trying to do is to work with
the the grain of human nature people who
want to take drugs who who need to take
drugs and personally but I should
mention that out of sheer timidity
I've never myself taken this is because
what passes for my brain is my my
instrument it's a bit like bashing your
violin if you're a bureau musician so I
don't myself do it but I do think it
ought to be decriminalized because the
people who want to do it I gotta do it
anyway and what happens if you
criminalize such activities is
demonstrated eloquently by what happened
in the United States in the 1920s of
prohibition you create a massive
criminal industry you criminalize
ordinary people because they're doing
something they they want to do feel they
need to do and you cause more problems
more burden on the police on the courts
and is necessary I think what one wants
to do is to argue with people about it
and say this is a very silly way of
doing things the world and humanity are
so extraordinary so beautiful so
fascinating that you can be on a high 24
hours a day just by finding stuff out
and reading and talking to other people
and you don't need these these chemicals
to do it and if you could dissuade them
from taking the chemical route all the
better but to criminalize them for doing
it it seems to be well it's like King
Canute trying to stop the tide from
coming in sexual services
well they're to I mean I think again
criminalization causes problems it
drives the land to ground it puts it
into the hand of criminals and people
men and women who go into sex work are
less likely to be protected or helped
out of that if they want to be helped
out of it but but also again it's a it's
a matter of
Liberty like the drugs thing like taking
alcohol like smoking cigarettes all
these things you might have a one or
another attitude towards them but the
idea that we know better than you that
we don't like it so you mustn't do it
that morality that I've chosen I'm going
to force onto you this is the source of
a great deal of trouble and indeed of
suffering in the world
and what we have to do is we have to
step back extend the hand of help to
anybody who needs our help to do it in a
in a kind humane kind of way but also
recognize that people must be allowed
their choices must be allowed their
freedoms
professor grayling do you consider
yourself a libertarian then no um I
distinguished between somebody who in
the European sense of the word liberal I
know that the word liberalism a term of
malediction in the United States because
of his political connotations but here
with the small-l a liberal is somebody
who believes that we must be open in the
way the John Stuart Mill in his
wonderful essay on Liberty argued that
there must be many experiments in human
life we must allow people to find their
own way consonant with their own talents
for for good and flourishing and and
happy lives to seek those lives I think
a libertarian that's a much stronger
notion that one that one says anything
goes it says it's okay to trample on the
heads of other people if you can make a
profit out of it and I and I think that
that attitude is is wrong we do need to
to get together and talk a bit about how
we're going to regulate things so that
we can protect the weak so that we can
and going to promote things that we that
we feel are good there but that there is
a space in the public forum for debates
about things like drug policy and and
prostitution and education I mean all
the different things that really impact
on our lives but I don't think anything
goes it's a parallel you know to having
an open mind they say don't have such an
open mind that your brains fall out well
the same thing is you know be be open be
liberal in your attitudes but not to the
extent that you just give license to
people to do anything they're like well
one of the policy debates we're having
currently in the states is on gun policy
how does that fit into your philosophy
yes I'm baby
well aware of that debate and of course
the Europeans look with open mouth
wonder at the fact that that there is
such an acerbic discussion about this
thing of course there is gun crime in
the in Europe as well we've seen some
horrible examples of that recently but
far far fewer such incidents and it does
seem that at very very least assault
weapons and automatic weapons and
allowing people to have multiple
armaments you know and in their homes is
a recipe for disaster
and the repeated tragedies of shootings
at colleges in the United States it
really does it does astonish people
outside that there should be such a
fetish ionization really of the of the
constitutional right although it's
ambiguous you know them is it about
militias in times of danger or is it
about individuals being able to have 15
automatic rifles in their homes and it
is a puzzle to us outside and I rather
hope that what they your vice president
is doing in the moment might have some
success well professor grayling to take
it to your drug legalization argument
wouldn't allowing assault weapons be
like allowing heroin I mean is are they
comparable now if people were entitled
to you to own and possess guns that they
only ever fired themselves then that
would be parallel to the heroin case
professor AC grayling is our guest he is
the author of the god argument among
other books what is your background
well I'm born of British parents out in
the fading remnants of empire in central
Africa and my father was working out
there and that was in some ways quite
formative and in that we were living in
a rather remote part of Central Africa
where there was no television and where
the BBC radio service said we were able
occasionally to get was very crackly and
so of course being being in English we
like to listen to the cricket matches on
the on the radio but um for adults I've
always imagined that the only the only
resource was whiskey and adultery but
for for children there we were rather
thrown honor on our literary resources
so reading reserve was
a major thing for us and I've I think
that must have been rather influential
because my tastes have always been in
that direction and very early on I came
across references to Socrates and to
Aristotle and to the great thinkers of
the past and at quite an early age came
across a collection of Plato's dialogues
in fact at the age of 12 and this was
because by the way a lot of you know
Brits regard to the Empire promptly died
of some tropical disease leaving their
the books that they've been using at
university to the local library and so
there was a collection of the jurat
translations of Plato and I took down
the first volume and read one of the
early dialogues the Pater is very
accessible called the comedies and it
was about countenance about Socrates
talking to this youth about what he
thought he meant by restraint and to
self-government and it's about this this
sense that that surely is the way to
live to live you know with a passion for
the philosophical debates and the good
news is if you do get interested in
philosophy it's a kind of license to
stick your nose into everything which
I've been doing ever since we're calling
you professor where have you taught i
tortured Oxford University and at London
University and just recently have the
founder of a new college for the study
of the humanities here in London where I
continue to teach philosophy will talk
to us about the college than the power
well our education system in England in
particular not not in the United Kingdom
in general because Scotland has a
slightly different system but our system
here makes people specialists very very
early very quickly after the age of 16
schoolchildren our high school children
take fewer and fewer subjects and end up
at University studying one subject
usually and this seems to me to be a
mistake for our century where more and
more people go to university but they
need a much broader horizon the view and
so what I wanted to do was to marry the
liberal arts tradition which flourishes
in the United States
with our own of Oxford tutorial
tradition which is the the one to one
very intense a very in-depth examination
of a particular subject so you get the
in-depth aspect you get the
aspect and in order to marry them you
have to ask the students to do much more
than they normally do in an
undergraduate curricula of course
undergraduates must party and therefore
they must lie in bed from time to time
but there's plenty of slack in the week
for you know to ask them to do more
and so our colleges is quite intensive
and we we ask our students to do a broad
range of things alongside their their
in-depth scholarly study and it turns
out that they they love it I mean they
see the connections they see how these
different fields of inquiry feed into
one another is it's a private university
correct it's an independent University
or all universities in a kingdom a
private in the sense that they're not
publicly owned but they most of them get
public subsidy some like Oxford and
Cambridge about 25 percent of their
income is is public money but so we're
independent and one of the very few here
in the United Kingdom but this is a
model which is having to change because
of the way higher education is funded in
the United Kingdom so another aspect of
what the United States has taught us
about higher education is that a very
good model is the endowment model I'm
told that Harvard University has
something like 30 billion dollars in its
endowment and I say to people when mine
damage is that big you can all come for
free forever
professor grayling in your 2011 book the
good book what is that and what was your
discussion with the Archbishop of
Canterbury well first I should mention
that um in addition to writing both
academic text books and monographs in
philosophy I've also written quite a lot
for a more general readership and not
with the ambition of telling people what
to think but to alert them to the fact
that there is a very rich resource for
thinking about the nature of the good
life and by that I by the way I don't
mean a sort of conventional kind of
moral life I mean one which really feels
good to live in is full of flourishing
and and progress towards the achievement
of worthwhile goals that people specify
for themselves always of course I'm the
government of being able to make a case
and to defend against criticism so um
the
the writing that I did in that respect
was prompted by the fact that many years
ago more than 30 years ago while I was
thinking a bit about different ethical
systems when I was a graduate student at
Oxford I thought to myself once I read
my way through the Bible of religion I
thought if only somebody or some group
of people instead of going to all these
texts and collating them at editing them
and weaving them together as they did to
make the old and new testaments if only
they had gone to the non religious
literature of the world to the
philosophers and the poets and
historians the essayists the Epistle
writers like Santa Clara Pliny and
Cicero and Aristotle and and others
don't they'd gone to them and taken
texts from them woven them together they
would find that they would have a book
comparable to this full of rich insight
and inspiration full of commentary on
the human condition which would have
been an even better resource because
would have been less divisive unless
military in the sense that of telling
people what to do but giving people that
the the materials to think for
themselves
that was the minute I thought that I
thought perhaps I should try and do it
so about 30 odd years ago I started to
collect the materials and I did to them
exactly what the Bible makers did and I
redacted them chose you know sections of
them I stitched them together in
different ways Kate came up with an
overall text which I divided into books
so there's a there is a book the genesis
which begins with the Apple falling in
Newton's garden he said four hundred
have a garden to begin with and which
goes through consolations and parables
and songs and so on but paralleling the
Bible of religion but there is not one
mention of religion not one mention of
the word god or goddess or faith or
religion Heaven nothing like that it's
entirely secular but to illustrate the
fact that had this been done we would
have had a resource of a very different
kind because there is a huge amount of
comfort and of wisdom in the
literature's of the world and I drew
from Chinese and Indian and I mean from
from all the resources in some cases I
had the great great pleasure really of
rewriting and translating and you know I
didn't give any references nobody will
know where these texts come from because
we don't know where the original texts
of the Bible of religion come from so
I'm you know rather hubristic Lee tried
to construct something that could stand
alongside her on the same shelf to show
that it can be done and to show that
from the human heart there has been a
huge amount that we can profit from and
you had a discussion on your good book
and the Bible with the Archbishop of
Canada yes indeed with with Rowan
Williams some years before he'd invited
me to have a discussion a sort of
doubleheader with him before an audience
about a book he'd written on Dostoevsky
dostoevsky's ethics which is an interest
of mine as well
now Droste of course was a very
committed Christian and in his writings
in particular notes from underground and
the crime and punishment and the idiot
he had tried to explore the idea of the
of the group of good and evil and Rowan
Williams is a fine scholar and he'd
discussed these ideas and wanted a
secularist or non-religious response to
them so he owed me and so when the good
book came out I asked him to come and
debate it with me and we had a very very
civil debate it was only right at the
very end of a long discussion about
ethics where we agreed about practically
everything that the the word God
appeared and that was sort of in a joke
at the end but it just shows you that
the people of good will and good
intention actually share a great deal
and the divisions only come in when when
people find that there are you know
these and these commitments of faith
that separate us so as the Church of
England been good for the UK well here's
a great for the topical answer for you
yes and no I mean obviously that there
are aspects of any kind of organized
outlook on life which for example
promotes charities or educational
endeavors and must have a good aspect to
it yes but I think the effect of
religion in far too many societies for
far too much of history has been deeply
negative
just recently for example I was some
busy reviewing a book in which the
argument was put that what
nineteenth-century American critics of
religion said namely that if if we were
still as religious as we were in the
past we were still believing that the
earth is flat and his response to this
was say it's not true because of course
Aristotle and others knew that the
planet is a sphere but I had to respond
to him by saying look in 1615 Cardinal
Ben Amin who went on to become a Pope
wrote a letter to a monk who had tried
to find a defense of the Copernican view
of the universe that the church could
live with and Bellamy enriched Roman
said you've got to realize that this
endeavor must fail because it is written
in the scriptures that God has laid the
foundations of the earth so that the
earth will never be moved that the earth
doesn't go round the Sun this is a
matter of doctrine and this is an
example which looks like an historical
example of course but it has its echoes
in the great debate by the evolutionary
biology and creationism or intelligent
design in the United States the day and
people fail to recognize perhaps that
Islam is a committed creationist
religion and opposes the evolutionary
biology likewise now evolutionary
biology is at the foundation so some of
the most significant developments in
biochemistry and in medicine medical
research stem-cell research for example
and in the improvements in the quality
of life for people so that when you have
policies like the one that george w bush
ran that there were going to be no new
lines of stem cells for a research that
had to be limited to the ones that
already existed this this is doctrine
this is religious doctrine getting in
the way of very important scientific
advance which could benefit humanity and
it's that kind of thing where all the
churches judge england is a very
Laodicean church but but religion in
general can stand in the way of serious
progress how has religion changed in the
UK in the last hundred years
what you know if you were able to
resurrect a medieval monk and put him
down into a church service in one of
today's Church of England churches he
wouldn't recognize the Christianity he
meets there you were mentioning that
you've been in Munich had you been to
the ultra panic attack in Munich with
one of the world's greatest collections
of ultra pieces and murals you would
have seen that the the the visual
literature of the medieval mind where
most people were illiterate was
powerfully coercive and violent I mean
these scenes of punishment in hell of
the sufferings of Christ of the that the
picture of the universe given to people
in medieval times is very very different
from the average Church service now
where we will shake hands and the kiss
of peace is passed around mention of
Hell is now no longer you know all that
often had unless you're in a very
Protestant mega church somewhere perhaps
in the southern states of the United
States and so the picture has changed
dramatically because the religions are
wonderful illustrations of Darwinian
evolution they evolve
all the time in response to criticism
and hostility from the surrounding
society they adapt one of the few
churches that hasn't adapted enough is
the Roman Catholic Church of course
which sticks to its traditional views it
doesn't go with the ordination of women
its views about um termination of
pregnancy and is always what it was
their opposition to stem-cell research
for example in a number of different
ways they continue to be obstructive of
progress and if she said the bat will
not Bend will break
professor grayling are most people in
England today atheists I would have
thought that the vast majority of people
are secularists in the sense that they
they don't want to be run by bishops or
or mothers I should think that most
people identify culturally if they're
asked you know what are you culturally
they would say well of course that come
from a Christian tradition rather than a
but it's a Muslim tradition or a Jewish
tradition but I think that even among
the
of the Church of England there is a
great deal of atheism among the officers
oh yes yes
why do you say well it's very hard to I
mean I know for a fact I know some dog
collar wearers who who don't subscribe
to to the actual beliefs they regard
them as symbolic or as having some kind
of a poetic or aesthetic or exhort a
tree value to them but they don't
believe that they're literally true it's
quite hard to imagine how anybody who
uses a laptop lies in an aeroplane can
actually believe in the physical
resurrection of Christ or the virgin
birth why well because they're just so
profoundly inconsistent with their
everything else that we know about how
the world works and so they tend to
regard them as being symbolic I mean for
example the number of theologians in the
Church of England now argue that the
significance of the doctrine of the
resurrection is the idea of we being
reborn to oneself a resurrection of the
of the individual and so this is a kind
of metaphor for it of course in
Christianity in general I suppose the
key doctrine is the resurrection if it
didn't happen or it's been Knightly then
there is no story there so it's a
difficult one
and when you look at the treatises of
theologians they tend to bury their
doubts and anxieties about the literal
truth of these things in amongst lots of
very long words so given what you've
just said about some officials in the
Church of England does that mean that
there is a lack of faith in a higher
power well you do get what could without
kumis unfairness be called the Fung Shui
tendency among people who've given up
traditional Orthodox religion the idea
that there is some kind of something in
the universe which is very probably on
good sort of Jungian grounds explicable
on the basis of the fact that when we
were children and the world was a much
kinder and better place and everybody
says that the things were better in the
past of course they were for each of us
individually because we didn't pay taxes
they when we were 4 and 5 you know say
so the world was better and it was also
full of higher powers who could solve
problems and rescue us and look after us
to keep us safe and that residual desire
for
for something is a very powerful
psychological impulse this is where I
think the idea of being an adult being a
grown-up intellectually of taking
responsibility and of living with doubt
and uncertainty which of course is the
great mindset of science and is
powerfully productive not knowing the
answers always but always been keen to
be looking for them not living by by
dogma but by accepting and embracing the
uncertainty that drives us forward and
which accepts that every time you come
up with a good account of something or a
discovery that that's going to open more
doors to more doubts the god argument
faith can be beautiful but women and
children in subordinated households in
the Bible Belt of the u.s. may not see
it as so when I was a graduate student
at Oxford I was friendly with a man who
unbeknownst to me had a wife and twin
daughters in a flat in the merry
graduate housing complex that the
university holds and it was only some
months into my acquaintanceship with him
when I called round at his flat one day
his apartment is you you say there to
give him something that he'd left behind
at a meeting and the door was opened by
a woman and it turned out that she was
his wife and there were these children
came to her skirt and she wasn't I
discovered allowed out of the flat
unless she was in his company and this
was very rarely I was shocked by it
and it's you know making inquiries and
thinking about it discovered that the
parallels between women in Saudi Arabia
and of course they're much much more
extreme example of how women can be
closeted away and denied access to the
public sphere and only allowed to enter
it if they're in company with a male
relative and that was the extreme form
but in Saudi Arabia but that to some
extent this sometimes happens among
people of an very zealous commitment in
in the Bible Belt
and I think it's worth mentioning
because it is a civil liberties issue in
a certain issue about position of women
in our societies and finally professor
grayling and want to ask you about one
other book that you've written among the
dead cities was the bombing the Allied
bombing of Germany and Japan morale I
didn't think it was um I was very
intrigued since when I was a very small
boy my great ambition was to be a
Spitfire pilot in the Battle of Britain
which would have involved time travel
better eyesight and my mother's
permission since I was only five at the
time I became very very interested in
the air war on the Second World War and
as I read more and more about it so I
came to recognize this equivocation
always about the nature of the area
bombing campaigns this was the
indiscriminate bombing of cities by
night not looking for individual
militarily important targets but just
trying to demoralize the population and
to hurt the population and it seems to
me that the Allied effort especially the
Western Allies the United States and the
United Kingdom
they had great duty the duty was to beat
not sysm Nazism was an evil thing and it
had to be defeated but we must never
allow ourselves to get away with
thinking that because that was the
overriding concern everything else that
we did was ok but we can't inspect our
own activities and the idea of
indiscriminate bombing of civilian
populations which we did
night after night week after week month
after month year after year during the
war with a great devastation of the
civilian population of Germany I think
it does require investigation the same
with the atom bombing of Japan and there
I don't think we did ourselves any
favors and we have to learn the lesson
from it we've got to ask ourselves very
hard questions the ends don't justify
every mean and so we've we've we've got
to be ready to confront our past and to
make use of what we learn from it for
the future